[Musik]
sich selber arzt logen und ich glaube
das geht vielen so wenn man sich auf dem
tonband gehört sollte arbeit am
bildschirm oder für ihr foto sich sehen
und mit ihnen erhalte unzulänglichkeiten
uns gar das ist nicht ganz einfach
animierter gewöhnt aber es ist
irgendwann mal sachlich zurück die
damals in der normalität wurde laut
bericht das thema leider ja furchtbar
das thema eher im kopf das nahm
irgendwen apéro nachbau 40 jahre ist es
eigentlich jedes mal schlimmer wurde
das hat natürlich auch damit zusammen
dass sie weitere sandig nicht macht
andere blüten tüchern und das skurrile
mit nervenflattern am nächsten sonntag
moderiert kurt aeschbacher seine letzte
sendung was treibt einen menschen an bis
70 vor der kamera zu stehen
und wie geht es weiter mit dem spiel
wenn das rotlicht in den studios für ihn
ausgegangen ist
davon handelt dieser film
wie bin ich am studieren begann vor der
kamera
um das zu machen was mir interessiert
wie zuvor andere ruhige und psychiater
ist fernsehsenders ideale mittel dazu
und akteure halt kamera als integraler
bestandteil von opel mit league für die
information könne dazu aber es ist eine
tatsache dass denn wenn irgendwo an
einem fussgängerstreifen rot die ampel
leuchtet sofort die lacher auf rotlicht
programmiert sondern das ist einfach
mittel zum zweck kommt es zu übertragen
oder letztendlich der inhalt ist
als mitglied des legendären karussell
teams stand kurt aeschbacher 1982 zum
ersten mal vor der kamera
größer mit den als quoten aber die
zuschauer im studio mehr erhöht mit dem
kochen bis ganz besonders vor
sie löst sie längere zeit ist kochen im
cruise alec tradition
ja das war schon fast sie verhörten aber
allerdings schließt sich jetzt langsam
den apple ii da kündigung vor oder
musikalische gäste sicher gruppe aus
holland die erste katastrophe sie machen
eine großräumige poker um den moment
will ich nur falle gemacht und haben wir
auch schrecklich gefunden aber doch und
jetzt weder gedanken vom team mini
kollege hynix zeit also dass ich saß da
ich sie und du bist so schlecht sie und
die braut von 610 luft nach oben aber du
hast bis ducati geschaffen und daheim
mit der ausstrahlung und nummer dank der
ermunterung und das ist doch so schön am
arbeitsplatz wie zwei muntere und
überzahl wachse weil sie finden
die haben ja irgendwann mal eliminieren
über die ermunterung nach einer erfinden
um ohne das merken wir machen
1987 startete kurt aeschbacher mit
seiner sendung grill pastell die fortan
für gesprächsstoff wirbel und
beschwerden sorgte
die lese eigentlich tatsache der
gebürtige bildet mit föhnfrisur jüngere
gestrahlt unterhaltungs 40 kultursprache
muss sagen im zeitalter von der coming
out muss man wahrheit auf den tisch
legen
oder doch nicht
und heute flüge mit ist wichtig sie über
sachen können ihre sogenannten und haut
xm die geräte wo man liegend mit bildern
konfrontiert wo im ersten moment
vielleicht lustig sie und im zweiten
muss man schlucken und im dritten fall
verlangen kann das schwimmen mini aber
zügig sie unterhalten schnitt nummer
oberfläche sich amüsieren
ich glaube ein einfaches mediums
fernsehen die aufgaben nicht
sensationell berichtet machen um
schlagzeilen zu produzieren sondern
glühte hans nau zu problemen führen
und vielleicht schafft lösungen einfach
mal sagen denkmal der übergang machen
seit 18 jahren moderierte ist eine
sendung aeschbacher in der zürcher labor
zu gast ist heute unter anderem ein
homosexueller schiedsrichtergespann
sprachen und sein team beherbergen
menschen die zum nachdenken und handeln
anregen sollen
dass sie die letzten 40 jahren
konstanten prozess bis sie vom lehrer
um lehrer für mehr sagen pro im umgang
mit problem also das quiz show dazu also
darum will ich nicht jede geschichte
betreffen jetzt persönlich ganz viele
sachen an die natürlich zum meer sauber
können anwendungen und umsätze also mit
einem wort ich bin seit 40 jahren
psychotherapie und werden dafür fällig
ist sieht dass man aber falls im
fussball privater so kaliber wie man
möchte ohne kenntnisse schließlich
geschossen
sogenannt schwulst tagesschau steht
jetzt parat einfühlsam anständig
freifunk zionismus das sind die
attribute welche die fans ihren spitzen
schreiben findet zunächst muss sagt ich
sehr negativ der zynismus schützt er im
der vorraum mit sich aber kritisch und
projizierte alles eigentlich genossen
und ich glaube gerade seinen beruf
verlangt viel persönliche verantwortung
verlangt dass man das was man macht und
nicht nur mit dem großer finger auf
andere zeigt sondern auch mit dem finger
auf sicht und immer wieder sich kritisch
hinterfragt
das bach moderiert seine sendungen ohne
netz und ohne doppelten boden kein draht
zur es keine moderationskarten kein
teleprompter
nur so sei ein intensives gespräch mit
dem gegenüber möglich findet er
juni vorigen jahres kam hinaus ist das
ganz masters wichtig sie und wir
bekommen heute reaktionen auf junge
leute
dank dann minimiert wird wir sie aus
verständnis aber das geld nicht in
verstecktes geld nun öffnet nach zitiert
führen
ja das probiere ja das ist eigentlich
mit news corp evita motors sieht der der
freude des kabinetts machen business
guide wenn die letztes antike bönisch
weil sie lebt wie hart sie haben mich
kurz vor gerettet aber es ist es auch
live sprach mit dem dalai lama ein ist
für toni in fragte habe ja als
wiedergeburt glaubt und saubere bietet
gebot ist wie nah der sich vorstellt wie
sie jäger tod wird sieht es sollte die
habe das land für profis thw sieht und
jetzt nicht wagen starben aber die lage
wurde mit schaffen haben wir das nicht
von seiner sich wiener bundesrichtern
entdecker muss ehrlich sagen viel vor
denen bilder der ausstellung hat
jahrelang die fast zwei jahren nicht
seit über 50 jahren ist kurt aeschbacher
auch kunstsammler es ist september glanz
und gloria berichtet über seine
ausstellung ja zum geburtstag schenken
wir so eine ausstellung von alten sachen
wohl die letzten 50 jahren selber
zusammen
ach so ich bin natürlich so finanziert
ja ja die ausstellung waren im einsatz
um sieben stück geburtstag schenken ist
ein blick zurück ins lager sieht 50
jahre sammle kunst hätten die immer
fasziniert dass sie wahnsinnig viel
bildet sammelstelle kunde 10 bildet
nicht nur von mir eine große stiftung
sammeln was mir interessiert hätte ich
auch ja frage kunst wie vor der
englischen künstlerin wo ein berühmter
filmstar zeit vergangen
[Musik]
machen wir kürzen aber bedauerlicher
weil das was sie macht so lange ich es
auch lichtblicke zell und am sehen ist
völlig offen wer noch für balingen
wieder merkt was man alles idee der
optik her schließlich wieder zu sagen
sie ja nie kommen würde ist das dreschen
jagd kabel sauber bestreitet herr und
meister vor die kamera ja natürlich
spezifische idee wie man es kennt und
seit machen und was richtig war von
busacca hat oppenheim soll nach dem
dritten anlauf hat der richter nach der
wünsche und ein anderer
das ist für sie eine ganz wichtige fotos
der vier jahre monat an alten zöpfen
wunderbaren zerstört und muss man alles
alte zerstöre damit das neue platz und
so danke mir bringt mehr kunst
wahnsinnig viele inspirationen wie mit
waldoch an das taxi
der beitrag für das people magazin ist
abgedreht von den kultur und von
redaktionen erhielt eschbacher auf seine
einladung nicht einmal eine antwort
es danke mit hat natürlich zusammenhang
mit der tatsache dass man befehlen der
menschen ihre schublade landet ganz klar
aus unterhaltung und traute schubladen
trautmann fällig so etwa im netz nur
dass rohre anstatt sich mit grund
kaffeefahrten oder das ernsthaft
interessiert ist auch musik und und da
ist eigentlich das einzige wo nicht nur
dass man nicht mehr neugier und
einfach wie der teufel zwick thomas lips
mit lösungen was der da dahintersteckt
unterhaltungsserie steckt er sich den
zauberer so aber natürlich so einfacher
schutz vor griff ich habe mir eigentlich
nicht anders definieren sagt eigentlich
ist aber lang jetzt die letzten 40
jahren ist sie per zufall im wenig
unterhaltung haben wir beim eigentlichen
sinn immer als unterhalter reseller
titulieren
also macht der sprung nach vorn
unternehmen eigentlich der begriff kraft
foods seine freunde und fans kamen in
scharen und ließen sich von kurt
aeschbacher durch seine ausstellung
führen
aus der zeitung erfuhren sie das
beispiel sammlung millionenwert sei dank
logischerweise in der schweiz nach dem
entschluss in mir aus aber brauche was
verdient wie viel geld vom konto
die zusammengeschnitten millionen hat er
ja immer was die künstler gekauft wo
jetzt will ich relativ boni und noch
offen wo sie für sie wurde aber es ist
mir als investitionsgut sie kunst aktien
oder nüsse oder was auch immer
sondern es ist verzichtet sie auf ganz
vieles andere
wo aber der wertvolle sammlung eine
völlig neue sachlich ist kurt
aeschbacher ist betriebswirtschafter er
war auch immer unternehmer und wird es
weiterhin sein im moment als besitzer
eines fitnessstudios und als herausgeber
einer zeitschrift wenn sie machen hätte
eher sachlich suchtpotenzial und
aufgrund von sagt man jetzt mal der
freund die arbeit machen sagt der mann
geschossen lila korrumpieren und die
amerikaner immer gesagt es ist läuft
sich besser auf zuruf trina bei als nur
auf ein wohl wenn man darin dass
probleme berühmte lange matte könig das
unternehmen sie hat ein großer vorteil
verschafft mit dem risiko ersetzt die
seite wo man nach der flut nicht wie
cosimo ex-freundin geld geld für oder
wochen und monatelang über sache nach
gedanke was mir die messe süd und mache
aber also unternehmen reden immer machen
und machen heißt fall machen will ich im
besten fall erfolgreich sie aber
überprüfen ob das was man im kopf hätten
vom markt und so an die zig
unterschiedliche schafften mehr oder
weniger erfolgreich probiert zu
lancieren
jedes jahr moderiert kurt aeschbacher
die modeschau des luzern der labels blue
coat uhr im kultur und kongresszentrum
heute feiert er seinen 70 geburtstag
es wäre im oktober sein einziger freier
abend gewiesen sieht anders aus sagt ski
und 384 tag gemacht sagen andere große
nitro kaputte autos hätte ja nicht
müsste jetzt gegen krankheits tür oder
mit einem reduzierten der reduzierte
körperliche möglichkeiten sondern es ist
ein tag wo in dem sie von mir jetzt ich
hab sie unter die bedürftigkeit auch
nicht wollen sondern mir da wird ein
anderer nicht
[Musik]
bachl ist auch aus rate fernsehstudios
ein gefragter moderator durch den
heutigen abend führt er für eine
großzügige spießen entscheid kommen die
arbeiter jungen schneiderinnen die ihm
am herzen
die privaten auftritte und saftigen
honorare vieler fernsehmoderatoren geben
immer wieder anlass zu kritik und zwar
in arbeit war sehr viel vorbereitet sich
bruch vor sehr viel engagement braucht
um es auf jedes mal exponiert und solche
völlig normal dass 60 jahre genauso wie
die vorfreude jetzt am harrl machen
sondern aber leicht ist die kreative
leistung bringt und dieser entschädigt
werden also da wo überhaupt nicht der
meinung dass man das nur über rom will
mit dem fenster schaut
aber natürlich kann ob ich profitiert
sehr von ihnen bekommt und in sliven ist
voraussetzung für eine kurze
bekanntheitsgrad ist gar das gilt für
eine budget etwas irgendwo im haus wirft
unterdessen aber auch genauso wie für
die jugend des brandes ob das denn
nachhaltig ist und ob es 40 oder 50
jahre funktioniert denn ich richtig
fragt und völlig muss man die leistete
aber neuen täglichen alltag bewiesen und
kann sich nicht einfach nur ein beruf
bezieher des managers bekanntheitsgrad
der medien übeltäter stürmischen großen
unterschied
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ruhe sucht kurt aeschbacher jeweils in
seinem chalet in davos
doch stille findet er auch hier nicht
ein tinnitus ist ein ständiger begleiter
die berber froh dass marbach haven haben
muss aber fließen wird das geht so eines
grund grüsch es geht im kopf daniel
stähli völlige sondern es geht immer
tiefer und rutsche und wenn gar nicht
mehr passierte wäre die plötzlich
aufmerksam dass das so ist erklärt
irgendwo findet schließe mit dem schiff
in den kopf und sagt du bist da okay und
der bach wo soll das große rutsche geht
hilf mit der sich die abgabe jetzt vor
dem herd was ich da immer träge macht
besitzt sein privat- und gefühlsleben
stets freundlich aber konsequent jedes
wort vor der kamera scheint mir mit
bedacht gewählt so konnten auch die
antwort auf meine frage was denn die
absetzung seiner sendung mit ihm gemacht
habe professionell daher im ersten
moment zweiter geht sache der senat und
das ist wirklich wunderbar die chance
darüber nach als dank harmonisch und
woher das wort lied verschnaufen und
slogan was auf mich zu und und da
hauptsächlich kloster bis mitmachen was
auch immer das wird sie
die haben ihre sache super einsehen
fotos mache der sparte mache der
pensionierte wenn die arbeiter er immer
versucht das wohl nie wichtig von der h
möglich zu machen sowie das ist
überhaupt nicht nur traurig sondern das
projekt also need to talk nichts